en este vídeo me gustaría ver un
concepto básico de aritmética y me
gustaría enseñarles un pequeño truco
para convertir un número decimal
terminal a una fracción
espero que el decimal que vayan a usar
no sea muy largo porque si no puede ser
un poco tedioso al menos de la forma en
que yo lo hago por ejemplo quiero
mostrarles que podemos escribir 0.5 como
un medio 1.75 como siete cuartos y 2.88
como 72 entre 25 entonces así es como lo
hago empecemos con 0.5 y lo primero que
hago es que bueno podemos tomar
cualquier número y dividirlo entre 1 y
aún sigue siendo el mismo número que
teníamos originalmente y lo que haré es
que junto al 1 voy a agregar un par de
ceros
mi objetivo es deshacerme del número
decimal en el numerador hay que
deshacernos del decimal para hacer eso
si multiplicamos lo de arriba por 10 y
lo de abajo por 10 lo que estoy haciendo
es mover
punto decimal una posición y también
vamos a mover el punto en una posición
en el denominador entonces si movemos el
punto decimal una posición nos queda 5
entre 10 y ahora simplemente vamos a
simplificar la fíjense 5 entre 10 lo
podemos escribir como 5 por 1 entre 5
por 2 que es igual a 10 y recuerden que
si todo se está multiplicando arriba y
abajo podemos cancelar los factores
comunes y así terminamos con la fracción
de un medio ok ahora vamos con 1.75
intentemos hacer el mismo truco
ahora tenemos 1.75 entre 1 y la idea es
que si en este caso movemos el punto
decimal dos veces nos quedará 175 y en
el denominador necesitamos agregar dos
ceros ok y recuerden si el numerador de
una fracción es mayor al denominador eso
significa que el número con el que
empezamos es mayor a 1
es verdad esa es una forma rápida de
verificar que van bien ahora lo tedioso
de esto es que tenemos que tratar de
reducirlo lo más que se pueda aquí es en
donde deben saber sobre factores pero
vamos a ver 175 es igual a 25 por 7 y
después podemos decir que 25 por 4 es
igual a 100 y así simplemente el 25 se
cancela y nos queda la fracción 7 entre
4 y si ponen 7 entre 4 en su calculadora
verán que regresan al número decimal
1.75 ok vamos con el último
ahora tenemos 2.88 y lo dividimos entre
1 ahora si movemos el punto decimal dos
posiciones hacia la derecha en el
numerador entonces también debemos
agregar dos ceros en el denominador ok y
ahora empecemos a buscar los factores
que tienen en común bueno lo primero que
podemos ver es que en los dos podemos
multiplicar dos por algo entonces
y los números entre 2 nos queda 144
porque 2 por 144
es igual a 288 y 2 por 50 que es igual a
100 así el dow se cancela y nos queda
144 entre 50 y aún podemos reducir esto
todavía más observen que los dos números
se pueden dividir entre dos porque los
dos son números pares entonces como los
dos son números pares podemos escribir
144 como 2 por 72 y luego podemos
escribir 50 como 2 por 25 así el 2 se
cancela y nos queda 72 entre 25 y creo
que ya no podemos reducirlo más porque
si pensamos en factores de 25 es decir
lo único por lo que podríamos
multiplicar y que sea un número entero
es 15 y 25 1 no nos ayuda mucho pero por
ejemplo el número 5 no tiene relación
con el 72 y lo mismo ocurre con el 25
y que ésta es nuestra fracción lo más
simplificada posible por lo tanto 2.88
es igual a 72 entre 25 ok
espero que estos ejemplos les ayuden y
por ejemplo si tuvieran un número más
largo como 1.234 789 será un poco más
complicado simplificarlo porque entonces
tendremos 1 2 3 4 7 8 9 y necesitamos
mover el punto 6 veces
entonces agregamos 1 2 3 4 5 6 ceros así
que tendríamos que reducir un número muy
grande no no voy a simplificarlo pero
bueno no creo que les pidan algo como
esto en clase en caso de que sí díganle
a su profesor que no sea mal bueno
espero que este vídeo les ayude